I don't know what kinds of exact weapons  they were to stab without a minute  like slashing weapons and they would  they would come at you there was  actually kind of a boss battle at the  end that was really really impressive  big thing came come swooping over like a  castle type area and just lands in  Freddy a ground shakes and this thing  looks I have to see fence I saw a lot of  rolling around in the in the in the  combat rather than you know in Dark  Souls you would hold a shield wait for  the enemy to attack they stagger and  then you go after him but and this is  just all attack it's finding strategic  ways to attack the enemy and again what  we saw was very short so I can't speak  to the the final product but based on  what we saw it looks like a fans of From  Software's games will kind of have an  idea what they're getting into but it  might it might throw a fans of the  studio for a loop once they